so turning out guys to something that
may be among your New Year's resolutions
healthier eating our next guest has some
tips that may help you with that goal
processed foods have been linked to
diabetes obesity and increased cognitive
decline and new research shows that
highly processed foods can be as
addictive as smoking and alcohol just
think about that Carrie Glassman is a
nutritionist and dietitian Carrie good
morning thanks for joining us
it's so great to be here happy New Year
Happy New Year to you too so we talk
about processed foods a lot it's a term
that's thrown around but what exactly is
a processed food and how can people
identify it
okay so most of the foods that we're
eating that we find in the grocery store
most of them are processed to some
extent so we all have to depend on
processed foods to a certain extent what
we're really concerned about here and
what this study was talking about was
Ultra or highly processed foods so
highly processed foods have had multiple
stages of processing they have the
addition usually of unhealthy fats
sodium and sugar which can be found in
multiple forms and they also usually
have the addition of other unhealthy
chemicals like flavorings and dyes about
so the question I have is why are they
so addictive and some may ask tasty it's
delicious yeah right well food
manufacturers are smart and they
manufacture they actually engineer these
foods to be highly palatable to make us
want to eat more and the reason that
these foods are so addictive and the
reason we can't stop eating them is
because of that combination of unhealthy
fats sodium and all forms of sugar and
it's that it's that really unnatural
high dose of refined carbohydrates mixed
with unhealthy fats that leads to them
being so addictive for many many people
the other thing Kerry though is and you
know you want people to break the habit
of eating these processed foods but
oftentimes people don't have a choice if
you live in an area of the country where
you don't have access to fresh produce
or fresh groceries it becomes really
really hard to implement some of these
steps so what can people do who are
looking to break those habits
you're absolutely right it is really
difficult which is why by the way it is
important to be even just aware of this
information so you know that foods are
made to do this to us so we can at least
be aware then what I always like to tell
people to do is to be aware of your
triggers and find some controls for
those triggers so if you know that you
have the habit of coming home every
night and then you go right to you know
go right to your kitchen and you grab
that bag of chips change that behavior
and I'm not saying it's easy but
becoming aware of your triggers you can
change that behavior maybe you go
directly to your bedroom and you change
your clothes first then you can come up
with some substitutes things like
instead of those chips maybe on the
weekend you prepare some sliced sweet
potatoes and you bake them and you add
your own little bit of salt instead of
having those bags of chips and then when
you're out because you're right it is
hard when you're out so what I always
tell people to do is be really
intentional with your choices so when
you're home go through those whole real
Foods as much as possible so that when
you're out and you do need to make you
know a choice on the run you still want
to make the best choice possible and
there are some better choices now even
some drug stores have yogurts and have
pieces of fruit make the best choice you
can when you're out and be intentional
with your choices when you're home and
you can do better
so Carrie you know I have a one-year-old
and I'm trying to teach her good eating
habits she's obsessed with bread she's
always asking for bread yeah
[Laughter]
um and Vlad I know you're going to be
thinking about this too what is your
advice for parents trying to build good
eating habits for their kids especially
when there's so much other stuff around
that they would really enjoy eating
a great question and I never like
parents to stress out about this this is
the last thing we want to do is to be
stressed about it we want to control
what we can in the home and don't stress
about what their what kids are exposed
to out of the home too much so in the
home you've heard this before I'm sure
but you want to role model you want to
eat those fruits and vegetables and
whole grains at home you want to provide
a variety of healthy Whole Foods at home
so that your kids become used to eating
those Foods they they learn to like
those types of foods versus the other
foods that are higher in sugar and fat
and also one thing I always tell parents
your job is to control the food that you
present to Children the food that you
put on the table it is their job to
control how much they eat so don't try
to control how much they eat try to
provide the best options you can that is
tough Adriana in the words of Liam
Neeson and taken good luck
thank you so much we appreciate you